hi there steve coffin um i want to
follow up my previous video which
talked about how the most important
thing in language learning was to have
fun or to enjoy doing it
and that was whatever was enjoyable was
effective now
i must admit that in some cases that's
that's not always the case but it's it's
a good rule of thumb it works a lot of
the time
related to that is the idea that in
language learning i always try to do the
things that are the least amount of work
i like to do uh effortless language
learning and i borrow the word
effortless from two sources one is aj
hogue
h-o-g-u-e who is a great
teacher of english via the internet um
hello uh aj if you ever have a chance to
see this video a great man and his uh
channel and his website is called
effortless english but
when i wrote my other source is the uh
is taoist philosophy or taoist
philosophy when i wrote my book
the linguist the personal guide to
language learning about gosh it's got to
be eight or nine years ago
um i began it with what i call the
parable of the crooked tree
because drunza who is a a philosopher a
taoist philosopher
whom i refer to in my book and his basic
principle in life was to just follow
what was natural what was effortless
and don't try and force things
and typically the taoist philosophy was
in opposition to confucius which had a
whole bunch of rules of what you should
do and shouldn't do
in order to be a great person
and drunza had this parable of the
crooked tree where his friend says you
know
this tree is crooked and his lumber is
not good for anything and your
philosophy is not good for anything
either
and uh drunks are replied well yeah
that's because you have to make use of
it for what its nature is so
you know a crooked tree you can sit
underneath it in the shade
in my i'm in the lumber business you can
sometimes some of those gnarly old uh
trees produce very decorative lumber
that's very expensive anyway taoism is
also about effortless
wu way in other words no effort you're
not fighting it and i believe you
learned better in that way so i'm going
to talk about all the things that i do
that are easy and effortless and
therefore in my opinion
more effective and i made some notes
here
so the first thing is
um you know normally if i'm reading in a
language where i read well enough to
read away from the computer
i don't look up the words it's too much
trouble
uh on the other hand if i can't read
well enough
it's too much trouble to look words up
in a dictionary because the minute you
close the dictionary you forget the
meaning
and so therefore i read on a computer
where i have an online dictionary and
where once i've looked the word up you
know as in link it's then highlighted so
the next time i see it the next time i
see it in any subsequent material i can
see that i've looked it up before i can
see the meaning and so forth so i'm not
you know just looking words up in a
dictionary and then
having to forget them
okay another thing that's effortless
when you read grammar and i believe we
should read grammar rules it's kind of
helps give us a sense of the language
don't try to remember anything don't try
to learn anything don't try to
understand anything
just treat it as a a spark an exposure
of something that might help you
eventually get a sense of the language
so don't worry about grammar
don't do questions if you're going
through and i as i mentioned i did find
an old
uh teach yourself check here
that i had bought
many many years ago and i thought i
would try and learn check and i found it
kind of useful i go through it
it has
questions you know grammar drills i
never never do them
however what is very useful is to go to
the back of the book and at the back of
the book you'll find the answers so
rather than
asking you know having to try to answer
the question racking your brain to come
up with the right answer just read all
the answers because then you'll get
concentrated examples
of whatever they're trying to test you
on whether it be the dative case or
pronouns or anything else so i find it
useful more than once to read the
answers to these questions again it's
effortless i don't like doing the
questions because it's too much work
by the same token
when i read something i don't like
answering comprehension questions i
would rather
have misunderstood the text have my own
interpretive interpretation of the text
than have to answer somebody's question
where i have to think about you know why
did this and that and so forth and i
have mentioned before the great
brazilian
educator who said that nothing destroys
the pleasure of reading as much as
being asked questions about what you
have read or being asked to analyze what
you have read so i avoid all of that i
mentioned the other day that russian
textbook uh on history which which was a
wonderful textbook where they had 20
sort of pre-reading questions and i
don't know how many post-reading
questions all of that is effort i don't
do it it spoils the pleasure of reading
and or listening
uh flash cards again i've now finally
resolved i didn't use flash cards very
much but i do find them a break they're
easy to do and as long as they can be
made as easy as possible so i don't have
the flash card with say the check word
on the front and then the answer on the
back i put everything on the front so
though for czech word
in our system we have the english
translation and the captured phrase i
just look at the front and i go through
them very quickly i don't have to think
i'm just being exposed to them there
again effortless another one is this
gold list that i mentioned previously
i'm i'm not convinced that it's
effortless but there are elements of it
that are effortless because you only
write the words down you write them down
and you leave it for 14 days you don't
try and rack your brain you don't try
and your brain you don't have to try to
go over it again and again forcing your
brain to try to learn something that it
isn't going to learn the brain will
learn naturally with enough exposure
it'll learn some things naturally and
it'll learn all things on its own
schedule and you can't force it yeah
here's another thing too i mean you
sometimes get the purists that tell you
that you must only use a monolingual
dictionary i never use a monolingual
dictionary it's much easier to use a
bilingual dictionary
if i'm starting out in a language and
you know i have no words and they're
going to rather than you know book
whatever
you know
knee-high in if i don't know
uh many words in check a monolingual
dictionary is useless but even when i'm
quite advanced i just find that a
bilingual dictionary here's a word bingo
i get this
beginning of a hint of what that word
might mean and i know that only through
a lot of exposure will i eventually get
the hang of that word but i don't want
to spend my time trying to figure out
what this check to check dictionary
definition of that word is i find it
easier to use a bilingual dictionary it
to me is more effortless and whatever's
effortless to me is good
uh yeah the other thing too is
don't worry about things that you don't
understand and don't worry about
you know elements of the new language
that are
basically very strange to you so
one of the things i find
especially when i uh in asian languages
but not only there's a tendency to
introduce the names of every possible
relative early on and in english english
actually is quite poor in terms of
defining family relationships but other
languages have many more words to denote
your
cousin brother
your wife's
mother your uh you know
father's father i don't know a third
cousin
older brother younger sister whatever
it's in korean it's in czech and so
i can't can't be bothered with it those
are concepts we don't have in english
it's very difficult for me to understand
it doesn't really matter
uh you know him her it's good enough
similarly with some of these things that
you know if you're in a language where
they don't have articles like russian or
japanese you're gonna find articles
difficult
uh in english don't worry about it it's
gonna take a long time before those
things sink in
conversely if i'm you know i still don't
understand all the explanations about
the aspects of verbs in russian but i
kind of naturally get it more
uh some of the time some of the time i
don't
i'm aware that this
thing exists
but i've read the explanations nah don't
worry about things that are so very
different similarly in in japanese don't
worry about polite language at first
because it takes a lot of exposure
in order to to have a sense for that so
all i'm saying is when you're learning
it's it's kind of i do believe in this
sort of taoist approach do what's easy
do what's effortless don't answer
questions don't force yourself to learn
things don't cram things into your brain
just do it easily exposure
to the language trust the brain
and
i think you'll end up learning at least
as well so there you have it effortless
language learning thank you for
listening